F plus g of x equals x squared plus 3x plus 1. Great thinking if you found this
function. To find this function, we simply want to add the two functions
together. So, we'll have 3x plus 2 for f of x. And we'll have x squared minus 1
for g of x. So notice, here's f of x and here's g of x, we're just adding the
two functions together. Write in the highest power first, of x squared plus 3 x
plus 1. This is the result of adding these two functions together, f plus g of
x. And let's see this on a graph as well. We have f of x, which is our straight
line. We have g of x, which is our parabola. And then we have f of x plus g of
x. It turns out that this is also a parabola. And remember before that we took
f of 2, which that y value was 8, and we added it to g of 2, and that y value
was 3. When we add the y values together here the value of 3 and here the value
of 8, we get a new value of 11. Notice that the x coordinate for each of these
points are all the same, they're all 2, but the y value for this point comes
from adding these two y values together. So, this point came from adding f plus
g of 2, but remember we also found another point, f plus g of 0. We found f
plus g of 0 by adding the y coordinates for here together. We had 0, 2 on our
orange graph, our f of x, And we had 0,-1 on our blue graph g(x). So, on our
new graph f plus g of x, we have the value 0,1. Notice that the x coordinates
are all the same and we get this y coordinate from adding these two y
coordinates together. This is f of 0 and this is g of 0. Remember that if x
equals 0, then the output for this function would just be 2. Since 3 times 0
equals 0, and we'll do that with positive 2. So we know this point is on the
graph of f. Also, we know this point would be on the graph of g. When x equals
0, the output here is negative 1. So, if we want to find f plus g of 0, we
simply add these two outputs together, and output of 2 and an output of
negative 1, to get an output of positive 1. That's were we get this point from.
And notice that this is actually represented for all values of x. Any input
that we plug in here and here, we have their sum. This is another way we can
think of their function using their graph.